the UN mission in Sudan known as UNS was
supposed to help the nation transition
from Decades of autocratic rule to
democracy headed by un special
representative WKA Peres it came after
the ending of another mission but 3
years after it was formed the UN
Security Council terminated its
mandate we thank the security Council
for positively responding to the request
of the government of Sudan to terminate
the of uni terms we affirm the
government's Readiness to continue
constructive engagement with the UN by
strengthening cooperation with the
country team to work on issues of
recovery Rehabilitation reconstruction
and development
support the tenure of the mission has
not been easy ethnic conflict in darur
an economic crisis and political
tensions presented severe challenges and
while it came at the request of the
government not all Sudanese welcomed its
presence there were several protests
against the mission after a military
Takeover in late October
2021 that takeover also derailed the
transition to democracy in
Sudan together with the African Union
and the regional block IAD the mission
tried to help steer Sudan back to its
path to democracy resulting in what was
known as a framework agreement for the
military to hand over power to civilians
by April of this year then the Army and
the paramilitary rapid support forces
went to
war Peres resigned in September despite
the UN Secretary General publicly
declaring his support for him Antonio
gues has now appointed a new Envoy to
Sudan and the Army Chief has this
message for
him we welcome the new personal Envoy of
the UN Secretary General and hope that
it doesn't take sides but if he follows
the path of his predecessor he will face
the same fate
this deployment was likely one of the
un's shortest mission in its history and
one which was not able to achieve much
in a nation turn apart by years of
political turmoil and conflict hea
Morgan Al jazer